تتكشف خيوط مابات يعرف بسرقه القرن في
العراق رويدا رويدا اخر حلقاتها مذكرات
اعتقال بحق مسؤولين رفيعين في الحكومه
السابقه بينهم وزير الماليه علي علاوي
ومدير مكتب رئيس الحكومه رائد جوحي القاضي
والسياسي الذي شغل مناصب عده من بينها
قاضي التحقيق مع الرئيس العراقي السابق
صدام حسين الى جانب سكرتير رئيس الحكومه
الخاص هؤلاء المسؤولون وغيرهم متهمون
بتسهيل الاستيلاء على ما يزيد عن
مليارياري ونصف المليار دولار وتهريبها
الى خارج البلاد
اجراءات وصفها رئيس الحكومه السابقه مصطفى
الكاظمي بغير المستقله وقال ان دوافعها
سياسيه نفوذ الاقتصادي يقودك الى النفوذ
السياسي الا في العراق النفوذ السياسي
قادهم لكي يخلقوا نفوذا اقتصاديا وهذا
بالاساس ايمان الطبقه السياسيه بضروره
الاستعانه ببعض المفاهيم الاجتماعيه التي
نشاوا عليها وهو موضوع الضروره السرقه
الدوله وكل مقدرته قبل ذلك شدد رئيس
الوزراء العراقي محمد شياع السوداني في
اكثر من مناسبه على ضروره التعاون الدولي
مع العراق لاسترجاع الاموال التي وصفها
بالمنهوبه في قضايا فساد مالي طول السنوات
الماضيه تقول مصادر من مكتبه ان السوداني
اثار في حديثه مع من التقاهم من زعماء
العالم قضيه الاموال العراقيه المهربه
معيار
علاقتنا مع كل دول المنطقه والعالم هو في
مدى الاستجابه والتعاون معنا في استرداد
اموال الشعب المسروقه استطاعت السلطات
العراقيه استرداد ما لا يقل عن 15% من حجم
الاموال نقدا التي سحبت من حسابات
الامانات الضريبيه لصالح خمس شركات خاصه
خلال احد عشر شهرا فقط واموال اخرى قيد
الاسترداد تتوزع بين عقارات واسهم في
شركات داخل وخارج البلاد وتقدر مصادر حجم
الاموال المهربه خارج العراق منذ الغزو
الامريكي للبلاد بنحو 150 مليار دولار
لم تنتهي القصه هنا ففي ظل فساد مستشر في
مفاصل الدوله تستمر السلطات المعنيه
باصدار مذكرات توقيف بحق مسؤولين كبار ما
يعني ان اسماء جديده غير متوقعه قد يشملها
الاتهام في قادم الايام
سامر يوسف الجزيره بغداد